a large youth mountain biking community
is forming in southern nevada the nevada
south interscholastic cycling league had
so many kids last season they actually
had to turn some away wow as kate
houston reports the league is now in
desperate need of coaches in order to
keep up with demand we just don't have
enough coaches we don't have enough
teams
i've maxed out now for two years and
we're starting to see other teams
getting close to maxing out too thomas
broder is head coach of the vegas
rattlers in the northwest valley which
is one of seven teams in the league 75
kids wanted to join his team last season
but each is capped at 50. i think
everyone for the last couple years just
wants stuff to do with their kids and
their family get them off those their
phones screen time video games this is a
way to do it and i think that's what the
appeal is and that's what created so
much growth each team is made up of
middle and high school students in their
immediate area the league hopes to bring
on 20 to 30 more coaches to keep up with
the 300 anticipated kids this season we
train people from all levels to first
year riders to veterans who are picking
up some additional skills we can teach
them league director dennis lefler says
a majority of the coaches are parents
that want to share a passion with their
kids once they start they're hooked you
really got these kids that never knew
each other that are now interacting and
the closeness of these teams and the
camaraderie when we're out there at our
events
people become friends and and meet
throughout the year and it's really fun
and exciting to see that happen kate
houston live local now
they are trying to raise about 30
thousand dollars for all the equipment
that they need for this season in order
to register to coach or to donate you
can head to our website at 8newsnow.com